I tell people my sister moved out west
your science teacher your husband he
renovate houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down I was on my story
before it was an Avenger
I mean mistakes
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of enemies
[Music]
is call signs taskmaster he controls the
Red Room they're manipulated fully
conscious but no choices I should have
come back for you how did the others are
their nose
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win of course from the best
but look into the past
okay you got a plan or shall I just say
Duggan cuz my plan was to drive us away
where your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
anyone
I mean my choice
I'm done running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen Natasha don't
slouch I'm not slouching you're going to
get the back hunched listen to mother oh
my god
all right enough all of you I didn't say
anything that's not fair
[Music]